cars you love them I love them I love
them a little bit too much probably way
too much way too I let's be honest fast
cars slow cars slow cars trains I love
trains - who doesn't love a good train
this is my 2015 Subaru BRZ I love it so
much 40 great to drive only thing that's
not good about it it's terrible to make
out it honestly it's bad to go on a date
in terrible okay
it has bucket seats there's low into the
cabin I also have this shoulder
bowstring
so you your range of motion it's great
for driving in the corners for making
out not so much and also you have this
transmission tunnel you can't even make
out in the backseat I mean you could try
but it's it's not gonna be a good
situation she's gonna think you're weird
it doesn't make for a great experience
so today I'm gonna be looking for the
best car to make out in definitely not
this one and to help me out I've
employed my less car enthusiastic friend
Garrett hey man does that car you're
always talking about yes so we're each
gonna pick a car test them out and find
out what make a car great to make out it
so what kind of car is this slow logos
got all those stars Subaru love oh I
have a friend who just bought a Subaru
because he's a dad let's see it yeah
oh right you feel like a racecar driver
when you got this yeah should we sit in
it
my man likes to drive oh my god it's so
far on the ground bad yeah what an
uncomfortable vehicle you love this
thing
[Laughter]
yeah it's a horse it's a small car let's
pretend that we're parked right no this
is super uncomfortable I think the first
step should be looking for more space we
want a roomy front seat but an even
roomier backs yes you think of any cars
that would fit that Hey ladies
this has got to be like the perfect car
to make out in right you feel like a big
man up there feel tall yeah I know the
feeling well it certainly looks bigger
yes there's no way that you can't make
out of this when you own this car you
just feel like you're in the rap video
all day hi it's a nightmare fun
nightmare it's beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no no I'm out what it's so come on it's
it's this wide
holy smokes we're so high up I feel like
I'm at big rigs like I didn't do this
okay so we're pulling up to a bus and we
look into this boom you're looking into
this but as high up as these people in
this bus are emerging I feel like
everybody gets the [ __ ] out the way
uh-huh
coming into this car I was like okay
this is gonna be ridiculous
but now I'm like I want to drive
upstairs right now I'm not getting a
little fat I'll tell you Rick we're
driving by a lot of attractive men and
women and none of them are giving us a
second look has anyone noticed that
we're driving a badass come on it's
yellow
all right this feels apocalyptic it is a
monster truck as kids you'd be like oh
look at this huge thing rolling over car
isn't it yeah but I was never like if I
had that car I could get a cute girl to
kiss me what does this handle for I mean
I got a lot of places to hold on to for
dear life yeah all right so let's say
we're on a date oh yeah you've impressed
me with your yellow car now it's time to
make out well the first thing I know is
that you're very far away from me
there's Xiomara it's a gigantic piece of
equipment in between us there's no space
in here this week is the space this is
like it's just going to giant chunks of
plastic yeah let's try the back well I
don't really fit much better back here
actually and my legs are really up
against this there's just not enough
space in here
I feel like it's like they didn't use
the space correctly they need a hollow
out the interior at all on the outside
it looks big on the inside it feels
small it's a bummer
Oh bummer - I'm ROH - so this is
actually a good point okay so if you
flip this down there's only about two
inches of visibility into the car so it
does provide a pretty good length sort
of intimate like curtain shape there's
the first real positive oh we've got
OnStar that's good yeah how can I help
you we're about to [ __ ]
so bigger was not better it was wrong on
that part let's try the other end of the
spectrum
I think it's kind of cute I know I don't
don't like it at all it's too small it's
a person's wingspan I should not be able
to hug this car you love cars I would
think you would love to be able to hug
your car the hood is plastic this is a
Tonka toy I don't like this I don't know
Rick I like it
look it's a little cute little exhaust
you got a trunk space that's about the
same amount of space as you have in the
backseat of your car that's pretty good
not even compared to the car this is
probably the biggest door I've ever seen
in case it's like attacked by a mountain
lion yeah as big as possible here get
out I want to try something right this
guy's cool huh no I think it's pretty
cool this is terrifying to me you're
getting closer I don't think so
closer maybe I am pop in
Florin it look at how small of a tight
spaces I could pull into this yeah you
know you're looking for a place to pull
over just to like maybe do a little bit
of canoodling yeah anywhere is your
parking spot the same time as soon as
you pull up to pick up your date they're
just like what's it's where's the rest
of your car pickup I swear I can hear
the Jetsons for glasses this wears
sunglasses what the your old crap bar is
just a pair of ray-bans so I mean the
steering wheel felt a lot of like a lot
of circles I feel like I'm in like a
bubble bath this is about the size of a
bathtub but that's very romantic maybe
you know when you're you like casually
kind of brushed their elbow you don't
know like do they like that you're all
about that we're brushing up over our
older because it fits everywhere you can
park anywhere
which means pick out but then also
everyone can see because you can't tint
the windows everybody sees everything
and then we can we can go to the
backseat if you want we can go in the
trunk and you could technically did
anatomy okay but I think this is like
yeah much better yeah we'll say that it
is better to make
all you're looking for is to make out in
the front seat of the car smart cars not
a bad choice it is
we've spent a day looking at cars yeah
total waste of the day that's a great
day you're trying to make out in a car
the best one would probably be this much
by the time you get into the car you're
already making out that's the first time
I've hugged Gary now we're best friends
[Music]
[Music]